( intro music )
( applause )
Juliana: Today I would
like to invite you
on a journey to show
you not judgmentally
but why we shouldn't
keep wild animals
from wild species as pets.
Wildlife trafficking
globally encompasses
many ways of exploiting wildlife
as it was very well shown here.
From the production
of souvenirs
to the creation in food items,
luck, religious charms,
fashion accessories.
Substances to supply the drug
industry or cosmetic industry.
Rare animals to supply
the international
pet trade for
collectors and zoos,
and the illegal wild pet trade.
Brazilians have a strong
connection to nature.
And as such, they love
to have wild animals
with them in their houses
as an accepted cultural trait.
Throughout my country,
from urban centers
to the most remote rural areas,
the bucolic site of
a house displaying
cages without wild
animals is very common.
House owners display
their cages with pride
as they show their
love and admiration
for nature and the animals.
They usually buy
these animals from
normal street markets.
They have no idea
about the relationship
with buying their dear animals
with the poaching
and wildlife trafficking.
As a good Brazilian
myself, I too have
a strong connection to nature.
Since my early years,
I learned from my parents
a deep love, respect,
and admiration
for all living things.
I still miss my pet hen today.
I began learning about
wildlife trafficking in Brazil
when I met the organization
SOS Fauna and their work.
I could not get over
the ridiculous volume of animals
being illegally
collected, transported,
sold, and kept just
so that some people
could have their wild pets.
As a good example,
as you see here,
this cargo was in just one truck
and it was carrying more
than 4,000 poached animals
to supply the pet trade.
I had to do something.
I just could not go home
and put my head to rest
on the pillow at night.
I started volunteering
for the organization.
We don't have one estimate
from the government
and numbers are
very hard to come by
but let's try to make the
picture a little bit clearer.
From 2002 to 2009,
federal triage facilities
received from collections,
deliveries, and seizures
more than 307,000
animals altogether
with a mean of
38,000 per year.
However, these numbers
may be even bigger
as just the state
of São Paulo alone in 2006
seized more than
30,000 animals.
Also, trying to use
scientific methodology
to try to estimate
these numbers,
two researches from
Brazil analyzed
eight street markets.
They concluded that
these markets alone
could be illegally
trading per year
more than 50,000 poached birds
valued at 630,000
dollars per year.
If we remember that Brazil
has over 5,000 cities
and each one has at least
one of those markets,
then we start to be able
to grasp about the volume
that we are talking about.
Withdrawing numerous animals
from a couple of species
from nature on a regular basis
has many consequences.
The most obvious is
the lack of animal welfare.
These creatures endure
so much suffering
through violent collection
and transportation methods
and then endure
a lifetime captivity
without social interaction
or exercise.
Most times in places
which are humid, hot,
and without adequate
food sources.
But there are more
profound consequences.
I am risking a little bit of
an oversimplification here
but let's try to understand
what happens to the environment
when you take
animals and species
that have unique
ecological roles.
Types of plants growing
in the ecosystem
will be altered if seed
predation rates change.
Also, if trees depend
on a specific species
to disperse their seeds,
they will have reduced
dispersal capacity.
Also, the ecosystem will have
decreased regeneration ability.
If predators are missing,
prey species may experience
explosion in populations
which can even become
pest to our agriculture.
On the other hand, when
prey species are missing,
predators may experience
decrease in their
population sizes
which can effect
all connected species.
Lastly, when less individuals
are left to reproduce,
this can lead to more
genetically similar populations
which in extreme cases
can even contribute
to the populations
or the species extinction.
Some people, among
them some researchers
who I respect very much,
have proposed that
we do commercial
captive breeding of wild species
in order to supply demand
without exploiting nature.
This obviously has
many advantages.
Yes, in theory it
could supply demand
for wild animals as pets.
We could learn and
acquire precious knowledge
on how to maintain
the species in captivity
which could be used in
future conservation efforts.
You could create an
industry with lots of jobs.
However, there
are disadvantages.
Keeping wild animals
in captivity
is per se a source of suffering.
Also, being in a relevant
business could also
bring about many
political interests
and this would probably
shape our ultimate goal
of conserving wild species.
Lastly, when we do captive
breeding of wild animals
with commercial purposes,
it becomes very difficult
to promote effective control
and law enforcement
of this activity,
making it very easy
and profitable
to make poached animals
look like they were
bred in captivity,
what we call bird laundering.
There is an even worse problem.
Honest breeders invest
great deals of time,
money and resources
to obtain
a limited number of animals.
For example, a captive
bred Blue-Fronted Amazon
can cost around
1,000 US dollars in Brazil.
Whereas a poached
animal from nature
will cost 40 dollars or less.
There are way fewer people
willing to pay so much more.
What happens is the
bigger consumer market
will not buy the most
expensive animal.
These animals with
very different origins
and very different prices
will supply very different
consumer markets.
In my opinion
commercial captive breeding
of wild species will not--
has not the ability
to supply the big demand.
Another problem, and then
we start to the solutions.
When animals which
were illegally traded
or kept are seized,
they have to go through
a very complicated
rehabilitation process.
And absolutely can not
be released anywhere
or we will cause more bad
impacts than good ones.
We have to make sure
they are healthy.
they exhibit wild behaviors.
We have to make
sure that the place
where we are releasing
them is safe.
We don't want them
to be recollected
and back on the black market.
But it has to be
able to maintain
the new individuals as well
as the natural populations.
They have to be released
in the same biome
they were collected in
for adaptive reasons.
Depending on the existence of
different genetic populations
within each species,
they must be released
as close as possible
to their true
population of origin
or we can cause
a severe decrease
in the offspring's
adaptive potential,
following mating with
the local population.
I was fortunate
enough to find mentors
that fully supported my ideas.
After so many "no's"
and "you are crazy's"
we decided to--
I just had to do more.
We decided that together we
would develop my PhD research
in population genetics of
some wild birds that are
severely exploited in Brazil
for the wild pet trade.
So thank you guys.
I would just show you
a couple of my results
among all the piles of
data that we generated.
Meet the Red-Cowled Cardinal.
( birds chirping )
And the Green-Winged Saltator.
They are very appreciated
for their beauty and
their songs.
I decided to study
the species to see
if we could find different
genetic populations
within each one and
see the level of threat
or if we could pinpoint
the origin of animals
within a known origin.
Ironically enough, we found
a different population
in the species we did
not expect to find.
But we did not find
them in the species
we expected to find them.
It changed a little bit
the way we saw this species.
This has complicated
implications.
Broadly it means that
releasing the Saltators
back in the wild
should be less problematic
concerning the genetics
criterion I just mentioned
than releasing the
Red-Cowled Cardinals.
Here are the three
populations of cardinals
that we were able to describe.
We would you like to know
if we could infer
the most likely
origin of some animals
seized in São Paulo.
These tests still
need to be refined
but they indicate
that these animals
are probably most
likely from a population
in Northeast that is known
to be a collection hot spot.
Data like this alone will
not provide a final answer
but along with other
sources of information
may provide a good
indication and a good help
for the decision-making process
not only for prevention
efforts but for releasing
in a technically
responsible way.
Towards the end of my PhD,
I wanted to do everything
but writing the thesis
to much the despair
of my advisors.
I was still not happy
because I felt my work
was really localized
and still small.
I went on and along
with Freeland Foundation
from southeast Asia,
I started Freeland Brasil.
Trying to organize
the work I was doing
and broaden the
impact so we work now
with three pillars
trying to accomplish
a comprehensive set of actions
against wildlife
trafficking in Brazil.
The first one, education
and awareness.
Amazing.
The brink of our civilization,
but a little bit too
long term for us.
In this component,
among other projects,
we are co-producing
a feature documentary on wild
animal trafficking in Brazil.
( upbeat music )
Voiceover: (translated) I
believe animals bring joy to us,
the joy of singing in its cage.
( sad music )
( monkey squeaks )
Voiceover: ( translated )
You are responsible
for all that you captivate,
not for that which you imprison.
That which you imprison,
you're more than responsible,
you're the overseer.
Juliana: This should launch
beginning of next year.
Also, that was not
enough yet so off we went
to launch research and
mitigation of impacts.
Where a student is analyzing
the mitochondrial DNA
of the Saltators to see if my
results can be corroborated.
I hope to start my
post-PhD next semester
developing paternity tests
which will be able to be used
in commercial bird breeders
to help law enforcement
detect poached animals.
We also collaborate
in responsible releases
such as this done
by the organization
SOS Fauna in which 80
Blue-Fronted Amazons
were returned to nature
following most of all those
criteria I just showed you.
This was only a
couple of years ago.
( birds squawking )
That's me almost crying
behind the camera.
If you are asking yourself
how well that went,
how about this?
And this?
But that was not enough!
See, not enough!
So, off we went to capacity
enhancement and articulation
where we work
with agents involved
in combating
wildlife trafficking
and provide training,
courses, and workshops.
The next ones aligned is one
with the prosecutor's office
from São Paulo
where they rely on
international
prosecutor's task force
against wildlife
trafficking in Brazil.
We will bring South
American prosecutors
to develop international
agreements on how we can
better cooperate against
wildlife trafficking regionally
and how we can join
the global efforts.
We also have an aligned workshop
with the Brazilian
federal police
on wildlife forensics
and best practices.
Lastly, we are
producing with SOS Fauna
post-seizure procedure
guides on how to
radically decrease the death
rate post after the animals are
seized by law enforcement
by taking very simple
and cheap measures like
this animal likes cold and
this animal hates heat, etc.
But that's not enough!
My next goal is to get
involved with efforts
to change the Brazilian
environmental legislation
and try to encompass wildlife
trafficking as a full crime
because believe it
or not, it doesn't.
If your country's legislation
is anything like ours,
tell your law makers
you want to change it
and encompass wildlife
trafficking as a full crime
as it is a crime
against humanity.
These animals are
being withdrawn
from the environment
on a regular basis
to be people's pets.
Should we maintain
the so-called cultural habit
just because we are used to it?
If commercial captive
breeding of wild animals
makes law enforcement
and protecting
our biodiversity more difficult,
should we do this
just so that some people
can fulfill their desire
of owning a wild animal?
If we fail, consequences
may be severe
and even not fixable.
Cultures are dynamic
and can and must evolve.
So I'd say no!
These animals in
all endless forms
most beautiful
and most wonderful
should be out in a healthy
and dynamic environment
fulfilling their
ecological roles
and their evolutionary roles
as species that
evolve over time.
Thank you.
( applause )
( outro music )